hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español en esta emisión
esta compañía más tacuba artista
mexicana cantante de rap con su música
le pone el cuerpo y voz por supuesto a
las realidades de muchísimas miles de
mujeres que sufren violencia de género
abusos racismo y falta de muchísimos
derechos entre otras violencias una voz
tan potente como necesaria veamos la
primero con la fuerza de su arte en
acción
[Música]
[Aplausos]
virus está en la calle en casa al
agresor no hablamos de gatos hablamos de
personas se lo gano el seguro ni tampoco
el exterior recién llamadas de auxilio
por ahora voy te real matado y no sé
dónde pasará no tengo la culpa vio lugar
solo que el hombre habló así no te
olvidarás que más de seiscientas mujeres
quédate en casa no pasa nada el estado
entre cuantas descuartizadas quédate en
que esa mujer si no te mata el único
peligro por quedarte en casa matarle
es el machismo más grande que tu
ignorancia estupenda es lo más grande
que tú diferencia
aunque mamá lo niegue de mi gusto mi
primo quédate en casa
saludamos ahora si amas tacuba
bienvenida a la entrevista muchísimas
gracias por tu presencia en france 24 en
español
o la que quiero estar aquí muchísimo
gusto gracias por el espacio para
nombrar me no por favor el gusto es
nuestro más está estábamos viendo recién
comenzamos la entrevista con una parte
del videoclip de nosotras tenemos otros
datos así hablabas de la violencia
machista y una de sus expresiones más
extremas más violentas que es el
feminicidio o no cómo y por qué nace
esta canción más está
pues nace desde una responsabilidad que
siento al tener el privilegio del uso de
la palabra creo que es nuestra
responsabilidad como artistas hacernos
responsable también de lo que está
sucediendo y de nombrar la realidad que
está sucediendo nos dicen que lo que no
se nombra no existe y a diario son 12 el
número de mujeres asesinadas en este
país por el simple hecho de ser mujeres
y creo que es necesario nombrarlo las
veces que sean necesarias y que mejor
que el arte para sensibilizar
dentro de la canción nombró a una
compañera y amiga mía que asesinaron
creo ponte minicipio también les vo
feminicidio en un estado conservador a
quien nadie en el país méxico y es mi
responsabilidad también es una necesidad
de nombrar y de hacer homenaje a todas
las compas que han sido arrebatadas por
el sistema feminicida en el que vivimos
matassi vamos hablando un poquito más no
de lo que es la letra de nosotros
tenemos otros datos el hogar no es
seguro ni tampoco el exterior decidirse
en otra parte de la canción el mundo es
un lugar muy hostil repleto de
muchísimos tipos de violencia para las
mujeres
en contraste cierto lugar para sublimar
o de alguna manera digamos canalizar
esas hostilidades y violencias y de
alguna manera quizás sanar incluso
si a mí el rate es una herramienta de
sanación y son más de 15 años haciendo
esto en el cual también he recibido
violencia usa la escena de rap me atrevo
a decir que mundialmente no es una
escena segura todavía para las mujeres
no yo sigo recibiendo mucho hate sigo
recibiendo muchas he recibido amenazas
de muerte por nombrar lo que él nombró
por ser quien soy yo por tener un
posicionamiento político como el ser
feminista entonces pues la lucha ahí
está y a mí me queda claro que este
lugar me pertenece y que tengo derecho a
ocuparlo entonces para mí es una
herramienta usada si no lo hago yo tal
vez no sabría si estuviera viva no y y
también es una forma de inspirar a todas
las mujeres a que nombremos nuestra
historia porque nuestra historia es
importante y lo que estamos diciendo no
es poco ahora más está hablamos de otra
de tus canciones vamos a hablar ahora de
autodefensa allí decís y te voy a citar
no dudes en usar la fuerza para tu
defensa pone al agresivo en evidencia es
muy interesante porque existe por semana
de alguna manera una suerte de
demonización o de estigmatización de lo
que es el enojo y más aún del enojo de
la verdad hay una crítica que aparece
mucho sobre todo en ciertos discursos
anti feministas que es la que apunta a
la manera no los modos señalan a
muchísimas mujeres de estar enojadas de
tener odio como si eso invalidar a sus
reclamos y el enojo sin embargo más está
puede ser una fuerza transformadora muy
fuerte de verdad además como no enojarse
nos y mataron a una hermana una madre
una hija una amiga si yo creo que el
autodefensa es la violencia más
justificada que puede existir yo creo
que es necesario no dependemos aquí no
hay ninguna campaña que hay muchísimas
campañas justo de aprendan a defenderse
como mujeres aprendan a jujitsu aprendan
crack maga aprendan a kickboxing lo que
sea no pero no es realmente una campaña
para concientizar a los a los hombres de
no hacerlo no acosen no viole no toquen
o no éste no hace cine no entonces pues
para mí también nace a partir esta
canción de un ataque que yo recibí en el
metro a quien en méxico fui golpeada por
un hombre por defender a una chica y
llegué a mi casa y dije no es posible
tenemos derecho a defendernos y tenemos
derecho a tener esta rabia donde es
evidentemente totalmente justificada
viviendo en un país que nos quiere
muertas literalmente vivimos en un país
donde las mujeres no importamos no y
todos los presidentes que han estado se
han encargado de dejarnos claro que las
mujeres no importamos no somos botín de
guerra estamos para entre tim para su
entretenimiento estamos para su consumo
pero somos vistas como cualquier otra
cosa menos como personas no ahora como
bien decías y como bueno se puede
apreciar en tus temas en tus canciones
hablas de tus propias experiencias
incluso contadas tu experiencia habiendo
pasado por un aborto espontáneo hasta
cuando alguien se manifiesta tan
directamente como lo hace vos no sólo la
música no me refiero a la vida en
general muchísimas veces se genera en
nosotros una incomodidad no hay como una
falta de costumbre a lo mejor a los
discursos tan directos y sin vueltas
notas que tus letras incomodan algunas
personas que se acuden que movilizan
y es muy es muy notorio sobre todo en
los conciertos en vivo ver caras de
gente incómoda en su mayoría hombres
también en mis letras trató el tema del
veganismo y es algo pues es un tema
oscuro que no toda la gente que hace es
responsable no sé para mí es
indispensable nombrar mi historia porque
en un mundo donde la música ahora hay
tanta vacuidad hay tanta superficialidad
y lo único que estamos viendo es
misoginia y
entretenimiento y exóticas y una
violencia exótica ción de una vida gasta
éxito exótica ción del pandillerismo y
todo esto yo creo que hacen falta que
nombremos historias honestas hace falta
que nombremos historias que realmente
han sido reales de historias que
realmente son testimonios porque mi caso
y cualquier cosa que el nombre en
cualquiera de mis canciones tengo muy
claro hoy que no es un caso aislado es
un sistema es una estructura en la que
estamos así y en la que crecemos de esta
manera y todo lo que yo he vivido no es
aislado a lo que han vivido muchísimas
mujeres no entonces también ahora
nombrará el tema del aborto para mí ha
sido muy importante porque es una
experiencia que a mí me marcó muchísimo
estuve a punto de miren esta experiencia
que yo tuve y nombrarlo para mí también
es una forma de sanar y es una forma de
entregar mi historia y decir no está
sola si alguien más lo vivió te estoy
acompañando no absolutamente tiene que
ver con esto que decías al comienzo no
del rap como un lugar de sanación más
está voy a citar algo que dijiste ahora
hacer mujer en estos tiempos es
convertirte en una fisura de la
estructura en la que vivimos y hablando
de fisuras hay que romper con muchas
ideas conceptos instalados esquemas
culturales de todo tipo y hay un
concepto que nos ha marcado a muchas
generaciones y estoy hablando del amor
romántico crees que ahí radica aparte
del germen de muchas de la violencia de
las que estamos hablando
uy yo creo que el amor romántico es la
forma de la estructura más factible que
ha tenido para controlarnos a nosotras
como mujeres no de repente gastas todo
tu día y toda tu vida y todos sus años
de vida buscando quien te quiera y quien
te quiera de acuerdo como se supone que
es el amor no yo misma sigo de
construyéndolo y sigo teniendo
muchísimas situaciones que que tienen
que ver con esta estructura y con el
entendimiento de lo que yo creí que era
el amor desde ver a mis padres de ver a
mis tíos desde ver a mi familia desde
ver a los adultos cómo se relacionaban y
creer que ese tipo de relaciones serán
sanas o eran las relaciones que uno
termina como queriendo tener no y al
final el amor romántico es mata asesina
poco a poco muchas compas no salen de
ahí y a veces también nos termina
matando en vida no nos termina matando
los sueños las ganas nos termina matando
a la autoestima nos termina matando
el autoconocimiento el amor propio o sea
el amor romántico es una forma muy cruel
que tiene el sistema de controlarnos a
las mujeres no me atrevo a decir que más
a las mujeres porque pues la meta de la
mujer siempre ha sido eso lo que se nos
ha inculcado de niñas es nos a los
juegos que tienes de niñez como ser ama
de casa a los cinco años como cocinas
como planchas como lavadas no hay y los
hombres siempre es como tú puedes ser un
superhéroe y puedes destruir todo lo que
quieras y bla bla bla y las mujeres el
sueño siempre es este no quedar
embarazadas casarte salir de blanco
entonces creo que el sistema de amd
pues le ha servido mucho no al final nos
ha convertido a las mujeres por eso
tanto el
evitar el aborto y tanto la lucha del
sistema para que no se legalice y para
que no se normalice porque al sistema no
le conviene que dejemos de ser máquinas
creadoras de obreros al momento de que
somos unas máquinas que parimos imanes
que van a servir para seguir trabajando
en el capilar el capi el capitalismo y
seguir produciendo dinero no basta hace
un momento decía que la escena del rap
no es segura para las mujeres estás en
un género dominado por hombres no y con
letras tus letras que apuntan
precisamente a la violencia que los
hombres ejercen sobre las mujeres cómo
repercutió esto en la escena de rap
dijiste que ha sido que has recibido
violencia verdad se ha sido difícil la
verdad es que últimamente estos años ha
sido más fácil porque me aleje de los
hombres y empecé a construir una escena
segura no una escena propia con las
compas o sea empecé a juntarme con otras
raperas a ser colectivo a ser comunidad
de hacerlo hasta una economía circular
donde nosotras mismas nos consumimos y
donde las compras que mandan nuestros
ciertos saben que pagar un cover pagar
un fee hace que podamos seguir
continuando este camino porque aparte
somos artistas independientes no habla
la industria nos quiere también como
productos y como clones y también luchar
contra eso es difícil a mí me ha tocado
de todo y a mí ya muchas más mujeres que
estamos dentro del rap no entonces hoy
en día sé que mi trabajo no es esperar a
que los hombres cambien porque mi chamba
no es educar a nadie mi chamba es
primero salvarme a mí misma sanarme a mí
misma y sanar a quien escucha y a quien
esté viviendo por lo mismo pero la
verdad es que hay muchísimo trabajo
todavía hay muchísimo machismo muchísima
misoginia dentro de la escena mexicana y
solamente basta con que lo busquen en
youtube con android mexicano y las
primeras cinco canciones no nos van a
bajar de de zorras de lo que sea
menos de personas no entonces es para mí
ha sido difícil hoy en día me siento
feliz me siento orgullosa del espacio
que he podido construir con otras
mujeres y creo que esa es la clave no
construir con las personas con las que
podemos realmente construir espacios
seguros y qué triste
que la meta mayor sea eso un espacio
seguro nuevos a creo que eso es muy
triste como nombrarlo así porque un
espacio no podría ser seguro porque un
espacio o un evento no podría ser
familiar por ejemplo cuando el hip hop
es totalmente de la comunidad del pueblo
para el pueblo de la familia de los de
las adolescencias que no necesitan tanto
no absolutamente más tacuba muchísimas
gracias ha sido un placer tu presencia
en france 24 en español gracias
muchísimas gracias a ustedes por el
espacio y gracias a toda la gente que
apoya a los artistas independientes no
gracias a vos una vez más hacia nuestra
audiencia como siempre la invitamos a
seguir informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y también en
france24 punto com sigan con nosotros
[Música]